Hãy bỏa bảo như 10 năm trở lại nhà chẳng, trong tổng mấy đồ nân trong tổng mấy tổng tham dưới thương đình khẩn cấp.
của nhóm các nước không nghĩa phát triển gờ bày, giòn tổng thống pháp em, anh hoài mà quân để sớt, giờ kiến sĩnh xa ngày hai mai tham một.
Tổng thống trong trở biết đã có lịch làm việc dạc tài dĩnh đàn kinh tịch tì dởi ở đa vô s, trong đó có các cuộc thảo luận liên quan tư quyền lành,
và hàng đình đã chưa đổi với những người có liên quan trực tiếp.
Tế bộ nơi đứa ra chừng bối cảnh, các hàng thử dụng đại tây dương lao thang sau khi Washington đen dây soạn phvy bổ sông,
đối với một số cuốc gia chỗ, nếu không chấp hận kịch yêu cầu của Mỹ liên quan tới quyền lành,
tài cơ hả báo như trắng, tổng thống trong tích tục bài tỏ hoàn nghi,
về phát trọc của nó tổ đối vẻ những nghĩ, chắc rằng Washington ngán chỉ vì quá lớn cho liên mình trong khi chưa chức nhận lại được sự bảo vệ tương sứng,
về phvy chỗ, tổng thống pháp em, anh hoài mà quân phát biểu tài dễ đàn kinh tìa đa vô sàng,
chỗ ở sẽ không khóc phục trước sự bán nạc, nhưng mạnh quyết ta tổng chẳng chủ quyền lành thổ vả luật pháp của tế,
đồng thời không loại chưa khả nâng đáp trả thương mại,
nếu Mỹ đã thuyết hai chương phần chăm lên các sản phẩm giữa ở bà sân phát của pháp,
chưa đoán một ngày chủ tịch quy bán châu Áu, O Shula Fond, Lêan cũng khẳng định,
chủ quyền của quyền lành và vương quốc đàn mạc phải được tôn trạm một cách dứt qua,
nghĩ bán châu Áu cũng quy định tạm dừng tính chính phy trònh thổ thống thống mạc xuyên đại thế dân,
ký và mọi hài nâng anh cũng chẳng làm lưới,
và hả nâng anh cũng không có thể đoán thổ thống của tình thủy đoạn.
Nói tần này, Êu sẽ học tương liền hình để thống nhất lập trường,
chưa đoạn thái của Washington, Êu trở biết đằng xem xét thái biển pháp đáp trả,
gồm gói thủy trả đối trị giá chimpanzee bà tiều rô,
hóa khả nâng kinh hoạch công cụ trong cụ ngay tình tế,
trong một cạnh căng thận,
dung nhá lãnh đạo trô, cạnh báo, việc áp thuy qua lại,
cơ đối cá của đồng mình sẽ gây tổn hạn yên chẳng từ quan hệ xong phương,